i think one of the
worst things that any government can do
is in a national crisis order the public
of whatever country it may be to do one
thing and then secretly themselves the
very people issuing the orders do
another and this lockdown party scandal
that's rocked down in the street i think
has resonated throughout the country
because every one of us made huge
sacrifices some people couldn't see
their dying relatives while boris
johnson and his staff were gallivanting
apparently on a weekly basis breaking
the very laws inside downing street
where they made them that they were
ordering the rest of us to do absolutely
disgraceful
understand just how brilliant the nhs is
go somewhere else in the world and have
an accident and see what happens to you
you know i fell off a segway very
embarrassingly in santa monica and all i
can remember is i lay literally drifting
in and out of consciousness having
broken five ribs and collapsed by one
was somebody waving a bit of paper over
me to see if i was insured and to tell
me how much this was about to cost me
whereas if an american had done that in
london they would just get treated
that's the difference between here and
say the united states which has a by
comparison a terrible health system that
punishes those with very little money
and is all based around pharmaceutical
companies making billions of dollars we
are incredibly fortunate to have this
system it's not perfect it's flawed in
many ways but my god if you have an
emergency you want to be having it in
this country with our doctors our nurses
our surgeons our consultants best in the
world
mikhail arteta well he talks a good game
but as muhammad ali once said if you're
going to talk talk you've got to walk
the walk and right now it is distinctly
unimpressive in terms of the walk so
arteta i think needs to step up and
start winning things or step out
i like taylor swift when damon albarn
from blur gave her a whack recently said
she didn't write her own songs and she
blew up at him and took him down on
twitter cheered her on i think she's
gutsy great singer great songwriter
great talent i like it